[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a france 24 nuestro
invitado de hoy es yuri latortué
expresidente del senado de haití es uno
de los impulsores del movimiento de
oposición al presidente rubén el voice
está con nosotros desde puerto príncipe
gracias por estar con nosotros es un
placer estar con ustedes desde hace
varias semanas se ha levantado una ola
de protestas contra el presidente y
bellido y aquel afirma que su mandato
presidencial va hasta el 7 de febrero
del 2022 pero según la oposición su
mandato de 5 años terminó el 7 de
febrero del 2021
se trata pues de un desacuerdo que nace
del hecho de que rubén el mois fue
elegido en un escrutinio anulado por
fraude y finalmente reelegido un año
después así que la oposición está lo una
presidencia de transición del tribunal
de casación
y en este fin de semana es un
llamamiento a aquellos que juran lealtad
a esta nación para que se levanten así
que una pregunta muy sencilla es quién
significa a levantarse contra jouvenel
moix
está pidiendo su salida inmediata azul
de pago y media
sin levantarse significa en primer lugar
que el mandato de joe en el móvil llegó
a su fin el 7 de febrero y 21
el presidente en el móvil el presidente
de facto quiere seguir en el poder y la
oposición dijo que se necesitaba este
gobierno de transición que el presidente
mes net primero para que si saliera
adelante y para continuar con el juicio
de petrocaribe pero caribes el fondo
venezolano de compra de petróleo se
acreditó que en un informe del senado se
descubrió que los fondos pero los
malpensados
segundo continuar con el juicio de los
crímenes de sangre perpetrados en los
distintos barrios vasculares organizar
esta conferencia nacional para que los
haitianos puedan dialogar y debatir los
verdaderos problemas del país nacional y
celebrar las elecciones honestas
creíbles y democráticas por lo tanto
levantarse es lograr esta transición y
permitir que haití se recupere
significa que no es sólo un movimiento
pacífico sino que levantarse puede
significa
también levantarse y tomar las armas
y no levantarse es un movimiento
completamente pacífico además no es sólo
la oposición son todos los sectores de
la vida social está el sector religioso
con la iglesia católica está a favor de
la salida del presidente el 7 de febrero
de 2021 la federación protestante que es
muy poderosa en haití que también pidió
recientemente la salida del presidente
el 7 de febrero de 2021 en el sector
sindical el sector de los derechos
humanos el sector de la sociedad civil
hay que decir que miles decenas de miles
de personas están saliendo a las calles
para exigir esta salida y poner en
marcha esta nueva transición
transición el problema parte del
argumento constitucional es que no hay
un tribunal constitucional que pueda
decidir cuándo termina el mandato de
todas maneras las naciones unidas la
organización de estados américanos el
gobierno de eeuu bailaron el calendario
electoral definido por juvenil moix
dicen que sus mandatos determinan 2022
así que no están de acuerdo con usted
cuál es su reacción
y me sorprende que la embajada
estadounidense haya tomado posición por
el 7 de febrero de 2022 cuando las tres
mayores universidades estadounidenses
estoy hablando de harvard la universidad
de yale y la universidad de nueva york
se pronunciaron para decir que el
mandato de jouvenel moix no terminó de
acuerdo con la lectura del artículo
134.2 de la constitución haitiana el 7
de febrero de 2021 y en el que no
tenemos un tribunal constitucional pero
el consejo superior del poder judicial
es la máxima instancia del poder
judicial se pronunció y dijo que el
mandato hecho en el móvil terminó el 7
de problema de 2021 según la lectura del
artículo 134.2 de la constitución
pero eeuu las naciones unidas la
organización de estados américanos eso
es toda una bofetada para usted le
indigna eso entiende por qué lo hace la
actitud de esta comunidad internacional
siempre ha sido dictada por el
expresidente donald trump
como lo saben donald trump firmó un
acuerdo con el presidente yo en el móvil
a un acuerdo muy claro y muy simple para
decir yo voy a protegerlo de las
manifestaciones populares porque hubo
grandes manifestaciones contra el
presidente yo en el mois por corrupción
de forma adversa ción de fondos y los
presidentes de todo el trump dijo usted
va a votar siempre por eeuu y yo lo voy
a proteger del pueblo y eso es lo que se
hizo
melo pero el presidente ya no está
no le decepciona que la administración
baiden siga sus pasos
la administración acaba de instalar si
estaban los demócratas en el congreso
los diputados y el senador leahy se
pronunció para decir que el mandato del
presidente joven él terminaba el 7 de
febrero de 2021
creo que todo un proceso que se está
llevando a cabo y esperamos que esta
administración cambie porque cuando el
presidente joe biden estaba haciendo
campaña dijo que donald trump había
abandonado a haití y que iba a tomar el
caso de haití que iba a mirar a haití
como un país que necesitaba ayuda en
este caso esperamos que esta nueva
administración que sigan los miembros
electos del congreso tanto en el senado
como en la cámara el gobierno firma que
varios jueces se ha hablado del juez que
fue nombrado presidente de la transición
y hay otro juez el juez rubén que le
deja decir que fue acusado este canal
además por el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de ser el instigador no sólo
de un intento de golpe de estado sino
también de un intento de asesinato
del presidente joven el mois cómo
reacciona a sus gravísimas acusaciones
pues sabe sobre esta farsa del 7 de
febrero de 2021 se habló de un intento
del golpe de estado y un intento de
asesinato creo que es absolutamente
ridículo en primer lugar el mandato del
presidente terminó el 7 de febrero de
2021 lo que el presidente ya no estaba
en el poder el 7 de febrero el 7 de
febrero fue la fecha del traspaso de
poderes pero ahora bien cuando se habla
de los jueces se acusa a un juez de
intento de asesinato o de golpe de
estado
bueno en haití existe el cgpj que es el
consejo superior del poder judicial que
resuelve todos los casos disciplinarios
cometidos por los jueces si pasa algo se
debe remitir a este juez al consejo
superior del poder oficial no le
corresponde el presidente jubilar a los
jueces destituir a los jueces ni
arrestarlos son falsas a estas
acusaciones
se trata de acusaciones falsas y estas
acusaciones incluso si las hubiera
deberían ser trasladadas del ministro de
justicia y el ministro de justicia
debería enviar este caso al cgpj no le
corresponde al presidente tomar
decisiones ya que es un poder
independiente en virtud de los artículos
59 y 60 de la constitución y es el cgpj
el que resuelve los casos disciplinarios
las partes graves cometidas por los
jueces en la cual cree que es la
intención del presidente joven el mois
él dice quiero terminar mi mandato
déjenme terminar mi mandato sospecha que
realmente quiere cambiar la constitución
normalmente solo hay un mandato
presidencial en haití para poder
presentarse de nuevo y quizás permanecer
en el poder
el presidente yo en el moisés el
presidente de facto ya que su mandato
terminó normalmente el 7 de febrero de
2021 el ex presidente hace tres cosas en
primer lugar quiere permanecer en el
poder desde el 7 de febrero de 2021
hasta el 7 de febrero de 2022
en segundo lugar quiere cambiar
ilegalmente la constitución sin la
opinión del pueblo sin sentir las reglas
protegerse de los delitos financieros y
los delitos de sangre tratando de
conseguir una amnistía general para él y
su equipo y en tercer lugar el
presidente quiere llevar a cabo
elecciones fraudulentas con el consejo
electoral
que está manipulando para poner a su
equipo en el poder y luego después
presentarse de nuevo para seguir en el
poder es lo que quiere el presidente
joven del moisés a pesar de que su
mandato haya llegado a su fin
como lo calificaría hablado de crimen
cree que es un criminal un dictador
ambas cosas algo más otros
hay varios delitos cometidos por el
presidente joven el mois en primer lugar
hubo delitos financieros
el informe del senado sobre petrocaribe
donde hubo casos de malversación de
fondos confirmados por el más alto
tribunal del país el tribunal superior
de cuentas y bueno la empresa del
presidente joe en el moisés agree trans
fue indexada y el tribunal supremo de
cuentas ahora recomendó enviar ese
expediente a la justicia lo que no se
hizo porque el gobierno bloqueó el
juicio la segunda cosa sobre los
crímenes de sangre el gobierno el ex
presidente joe en el móvil armó a la
gente en los barrios pobres queda
tenemos toda una serie de pandillas en
estos barrios y estas pandillas han
cometido masacres y por ejemplo las
masacres que en las salinas donde un
centenar de personas fueron asesinadas
la masacre en bel-air por eso creo que
hoy la oposición pide un juicio por
estos crímenes financieros y de sangre
sugiere que es un dictador que se
presenta como demócrata pero que hará
cualquier cosa para mantenerse en el
poder incluido recurrir a la fuerza
y personal
playstation de mojar si el dictador es
el que tiene el poder personal y
eliminar todas las instituciones
democráticas nunca se basa en las
instituciones el presidente destituyó a
todo el senado a pesar de que había
senadores que aún tenían mandato el
presidente emitió un decreto para
limitar el poder del tribunal de cuentas
para evitar cualquier control el
presidente hu biera los jueces a pesar
de que la constitución dice que los
jueces son inamovibles el presidente
emitió decretos para garantizar que no
hubiera adjudicaciones a pesar de que
desde 2006 todos los contratos estatales
debían seguir el procedimiento de
adjudicación
en todo haití no hay más que la
presidencia no hay más que el presidente
yo en el móvil no hay más control no hay
más parlamentos no hay más sistema
judicial además desde ayer todo el
sistema judicial está en huelga hasta
que se respeten las leyes y la
constitución del país
no solo que el presidente gobierne solo
con decretos más de 50 decretos sobre
todos los asuntos generales y sobre la
cuestión del país es un dictador
y la tortura le agradezco mucho haber
estado en france24 desde puerto príncipe
y gracias por ver esta entrevista